speaking of BS and nonsense how about
the view uh here's Joy Behar and she
really doesn't want this Trump guy to
run and she wants the government to stop
him okay now that Donald Trump is a
wounded animal this is the exact time
when Mary Garland should swoop in and
indict him this is why because bouncing
well that's exactly why he's announcing
it already Merrick Garland is a day late
in the dollar short he should have done
that this morning before this guy
announced but he didn't do it yet which
makes it now it looks as though it's
political which is what Marigold was
trying to avoid
once again confession through projection
right they admit what they are while
sort of claiming it's what we are right
they we're the fascists she's literally
saying that the Attorney General should
have arrested this guy in essence so
that he couldn't announce he's running
for president that's not really how it
works in a free Society with due process
Joy also for the last six years we've
been dealing with this whether it was
Russia collusion and impeachment one and
he drank water with two heads arrest the
guy and 25th amendment to him and he fed
some football players hamburgers and he
eats his steak with ketchup these are
all horrible things he uses he has two
scoops of ice cream and he must be
stopped even though Joe Biden's always
eating ice cream and it's fun when Joe
Biden does it anyway the idea that
Merrick Garland should be looking at
whatever whatever evidence or
non-evidence he has from the Mar-A-Lago
raid right you know
again it's just so obvious nothing's
going to come of that it really is
obvious I was off the grid in August
when it happened when I came back in
September I was just like well oh it
just sounds like another one of the
things like it's another one of the
scandals that's a non-scandal oh my God
Donald Trump Jr had lunch with a Russian
for 15 minutes in 2015 on the Upper East
Side my God we must impeach his dad they
want to keep this endless hysteria but
it's it's not just about the endless
this area they want to use the levers of
the state to in essence jail and stop
their political opponents I don't think
Republicans are doing that are they I
don't think so but we got more from uh
from The View here's some excellent
political analysis by noted racist Sonny
Austin gotcha moments like haha that's
you're in Martha's Vineyard now look how
clever I am I thought he looked like the
devil in doing that he did yes Ron
DeSantis looks like the devil because he
sent a couple people up to Liberal Haven
Martha's Vineyard you know you didn't
care sunny when these people overrun all
the Border towns in Texas you just don't
care about those people because you
think those people they live in Texas
and they're backwards and stupid so they
should just have it but if they freaking
send 20 migrants or 20-year legals to
Martha's Vineyard it was nuts you guys
all know the story within 24 hours the
National Guard the entire media
establishment everything turned so that
they could boot these people roughly 20
people they could boot them off Martha's
Vineyard Barack Obama has a 30 acre
Waterfront mansion He could have put up
a tent
we would have sent it to him I would
have sent him a few tents to put up in
his backyard actually it's his front
yard because they got a great view of
the ocean over there but they did not do
that